now a covet 19 vaccine is now obligatory
in the commorus islands but the country
is going further than most with their
mandate dw's southern africa
correspondent adrian kriesch has more
from the comoros capital moroni
a military police checkpoint the cars
can't pass without a valid covert
vaccination certificate the jab against
the coronavirus is mandatory for all
adults on the comoros islands
so i think we already had a lot of time
for sensibilization
so now we are not forcing people but we
just
we just influenced them to go and
vaccinate critics of president azalea
asumani call his rule autocratic he
issued the vaccine mandate in december
by presidential decree
if you forgot your vaccination card you
are allowed to ask a friend or family
member to bring it here then it will be
controlled if you haven't been
vaccinated though or you're late for
your second jab you will have to pay a
fine and you will be brought directly to
the vaccination center
in this case they were brought to the
military police hospital around the
corner 58 people were vaccinated the
morning we filmed whether they wanted
the jab or not
personally i don't totally trust the
vaccines we shouldn't be forced to get
vaccinated
vaccinations should be debated among the
general public and the comoros
we need to consent to be vaccinated and
not be forced like this like animals
like sheep or cows we're human beings we
have rights
in the country's biggest hospital dr
ibrahim jabir defended the strict
measures he is one of the coordinators
of the national covet campaign
it's a good idea to make vaccination
obligatory
people aren't respecting covet
regulations like social distancing
vaccinating people is the only way we
can save lives
and this is proven by the statistics
less than 40 covet patients are
currently hospitalized on the comoros
islands dr jabir says none of them are
vaccinated
the country is using china's cynopharm
vaccination in its nationwide campaign
several studies suggest two doses of the
vaccine are less effective against the
omicron variant dr jabir rejects the
idea
that's not true
there is proof so there is no point
arguing about it
we had more than 3 000 positive cases
around the country during the last wave
with less than 10 deaths
back at the checkpoint the majority of
those passing through have had their
jabs it is virtually impossible to do
anything on the comoros islands
otherwise a coveted vaccination
certificate is needed to enter banks
schools and government buildings and
even to take the bus